and today I can announce
that we are adding 35 more individuals
to that list
including influential leaders of the
state-owned Energy company gazpromp and
sanctioning six energy sector entities
[Applause]
we will continue to tighten the screws
on anyone a betting this illegal
invasion and we intend to impose new
sanctions on members of the Russian
Justice and security sectors including
police officers and investigators
prosecutors judges and prison officials
anyone involved in growth and systemic
human rights violations against Russian
opposition leaders
[Applause]
Putin's War Machine cannot be permitted
to act with impunity it's war crimes
cannot go unpunished that's why we're
working closely with the international
criminal court to support its
investigation into the atrocities
committed in Ukraine
as part of this Canada has sent a team
of Highly specialized RCMP officers to
The Hague
Canada will continue to do all it can to
hold Putin and his enablers
responsible for their illegal and
unjustifiable invasion